Пасторальний рай у західній Білорусі.
На тиждень цей тихий мальовничий регіон
опиниться в центрі уваги світової політики.
Саме тут, у білоруському селі Вайшна́рышкі
поблизу кордону з Литвою
дві колишні радянські республіки, Росія та Білорусь,
планують розім’яти військові м’язи.
Із сонного села Вайшна́рышкі перетворяться на театр військових дій:
ворог піде в наступ, але його зупинять російські солдати.
Принаймні, такий сценарій маневрів.
А що місцеві думають про спільні з Росією військові навчання?
Олена разом з чоловіком переїхала сюди з Мінська.
Вона хоче тільки одного – спокою та тиші.
Я негативно ставлюся до будь-яких навчань на нашій території.
Якщо це російські навчання,
чому їх треба проводити поблизу західного кордону?
Це схоже на крок до залякування, так би мовити.
У Франца інша точка зору.
Принаймні перед телекамерами.
Батьківщину треба захищати.
НАТО тут поруч базується.
То чому нам не влаштувати навчань?
Обов’язково треба.
Бабця Йозефіна про плани військових нічого не чула.
Але коли ми розповідаємо, її відповідь дуже чітка.
Я їх не хочу. Я проти цього.
А ось ці демонстрації пройшли в Мінську на вихідних.
Опозиція влаштувала протести проти спільних
російсько-білоруських маневрів
і проти військової присутності Росії у Білорусі.
Мені не подобається, що у нас російські війська.
Для мене це підрив моєї безпеки.
Білоруська поліція дозволила провести цю акцію протесту,
хоча зазвичай розганяє виступи незгодних.
За лічені дні до початку навчань
уряд Білорусі вирішив уникнути конфронтації.
Щоправда, на протести вийшли тільки кількасот людей.
А тим часом життя у Вайшна́рышках наче завмерло
на тлі військових навчань.
Щойно вони відгримлять,
люди повернуться до своїх сільських турбот.